salut aujourd'hui nous tentons en format
un petit peu différent que j'ai appelé
je sais pas encore comment mais vous
avez dû voir un nom de format un nom de
concept dans le titre et on commence le
premier épisode avec le changement
d'heure parce que ça c'est une chaîne
qui colle à l'actu mon pote et ouais on
rigole pas sur la qui brûlante du coup
on perd une heure enfin c'est toujours
la même question si j'avance ma montre
d'une heure est-ce que je dors plus
est-ce que je dors moins de ma matin
c'est pas anodin ça comme question parce
que oui qu'on le veuille ou non une
heure en plus ou en moins ça bouscule
complètement notre métabolisme et ça
demande quand même un temps d'adaptation
et porte nouveau concept je suis allé
chercher des vidéos sur Lina le site
d'archives des vidéos de l'époque où le
dispositif du changement d'heure a été
appliqué c'est ça en fait le concept et
je me suis rendu compte que même 48 ans
après 48 ans c'est énorme et ben on
galère toujours à savoir si on recule si
on avance d'une heure d'ailleurs
pourquoi un jour on a décidé de passer à
l'heure d'été ou à l'heure d'hiver
est-ce que c'est vraiment utile pourquoi
tous les pays ne le font pas et pourquoi
nous on le fait toujours et puis surtout
c'est quoi les les conséquences sur nous
ça fait beaucoup là non
[Musique]
le changement d'heure a été instauré en
France en 1975 à la suite du choc
pétrolier de 73 qui avait fait s'envoler
les prix du pétrole l'envolée du prix de
l'énergie et la nécessité de servir en
priorité l'industrie imposeront
également de nouvelles économies aux
particuliers j'indique par exemple que
nous serons en conduits à fixer une
heure de printemps une heure d'été pour
mieux faire coïncider le jour et la
journée c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a permis
l'arnaque des avions renifleurs dont je
vous parlais le mois dernier en vidéo si
vous n'avez pas vu cette histoire je la
mettrais dans la description en 75 en
changeant d'heures on pouvait faire des
économies d'énergie sur l'éclairage
artificiel le soir parce qu'on
bénéficier de la lumière du jour un
petit peu plus longtemps ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'en avançant d'une
heure on bénéficié par exemple à 20h de
la lumière qu'on aurait eu naturellement
à 19h ça signifie quand même et c'est
pas rien qu'on se décale de leur solaire
l'heure qu'on appelle leur normal à
l'époque c'est un bouleversement
aujourd'hui on sait tous adapté à ce
changement d'heure où on trouve ça
normal on a l'habitude mais en 75
c'était nouveau pour tout le monde que
ce soit pour les particuliers les
entreprises les administrations c'était
capital que ce soit bien intégré au
risque d'avoir des vrais désagréments et
le plus gros vecteur de communication de
l'époque à la télévision qui était pour
le mois très didactique
dimanche 0 heure et 1h du matin c'est la
même chose le changement d'heure
finalement c'est très simple j'ai pris
ma petite pendule mon petit réveil comme
d'habitude et je vais vous montrer voilà
l'opération qu'il faut faire il est
minuit à ma pendule je tourne je tourne
toujours je tourne encore une heure du
matin voilà nous avons changé d'heure le
changement de d'heure c'est très simple
voici l'heure d'été
le passage à la nouvelle heure d'été de
0 à 1h n'est qu'un exemple car la
nouvelle heure on fera en vigueur
légalement demain à 0 heure 59 minutes
59 secondes c'est à ce moment qu'il
faudra avancer sa pendule d'une heure et
c'est en 1998 que le changement d'heure
c'est harmonisé à l'échelle européenne
parce que avant ça vous le sentez venir
chaque pays définissait sa propre date
de changement d'heure je vous laisse
imaginer le bordel que c'était en France
le dimanche 28 mars 76 à 1h du matin il
sera deux heures pas tout à fait une
plaisanterie car ce jour-là le dimanche
28 mars nous allons passer à l'heure
d'été et nous allons tous avancer notre
montre d'une heure les Anglais et les
Irlandais auront fait de même une
semaine avant plus une heure et les
Italiens toucheront aussi à leur montre
deux mois plus tard pour avancer eux
aussi d'une heure ajoutez à ce petit
casse-tête européen que les Allemands
les Hollandais les Danois etc ne change
pas d'horaire d'été si aujourd'hui avec
le numérique le changement d'heure il se
fait quasiment automatiquement sur tous
les appareils les portables ordinateurs
voiture en gros sur tout ce qui est
connecté à l'époque tout le monde devait
ajuster sa montre et ses réveils
manuellement ou alors on utilisait la
bonne vieille méthode d'avoir l'heure de
son micro-ondes qu'à une heure de retard
pendant 6 mois et puis après on se dit
on va pas le changer parce que tu me
mets on va bientôt changer d'art si tu
connais assis il y avait aussi les
coques qui chantent au lever du jour eux
c'était pas facile c'était pas facile de
les régler manuellement et lui il a
l'habitude de chanter à 6h30
c'est-à-dire c'est la pointe du jour et
lui c'est un réveil pour nous et nous ne
pouvons pas régler la montre sur lui car
lui on peut pas le changer lui c'est à
dire qu'ils sont en train quand vous
serez réveillé d'abord évidemment oui il
y a pas moyen de bien sûr de régler
comme un réveil
les agriculteurs et les fermiers sont
ceux qui depuis longtemps sont contre ce
dispositif et on peut le comprendre les
animaux vivent en effet au rythme du
soleil donc s'il fait jour plus tard ce
corps de métier finit ses journées plus
tard pas le choix mais il y a pas que
les agriculteurs qui s'inquiétaient
d'avoir des conséquences de subir des
choses certains corps de métiers avaient
peur d'avoir des pertes financières des
soucis de logistiques comme les
transports les administrations les
écoles ou encore un sujet encore plus
important à l'époque au point d’en faire
un reportage à la une dans le JT les
bacs ceux qui sont plus touchés je pense
ce sont les bars les bars avec des
grands comptoirs ou leurs clientèle est
vraiment habitué à rester sur le bain
pendant très très longtemps
on parlez des piliers de bars
ça le temps mauvaise soirée pour les
piliers de bar là
ils sont frais le lundi matin pour aller
travailler alors bien sûr comme tout
changement il y avait ceux qui voyaient
d'avoir le positif que ça allait
engendrer au niveau des économies
d'énergie mais il y avait aussi ceux qui
étaient parfaitement contre révoltées
en Bretagne par exemple ils ont excusez
le système en continuant de vivre à leur
solaire quand ils arrivent ici par
exemple là ils sont là il est midi
le bastion des partisans de leur solaire
nous sommes bretons avant tout et donc
on vit à notre heure c'est à dire leur
solaire pas question de changer pourquoi
changer tout le monde vit pas à Paris
autour d'un ministère si on vit nature
dans la nature et notre environnement
c'est la vie c'est l'homme c'est tout et
à Paris on dit donc en liberté
surveiller
vous buvez tous en liberté surveillée
donc en 1998 le changement d'heure est
harmonisé dans l'Union européenne même
si les fuseaux horaires sont différents
par exemple le Portugal est calé sur
l'heure de l'Europe
occidentale et la Finlande sur l'heure
de l'Europe orientale malgré tous les
deux pays change leur montre au même
moment le même jour il est donc 2-0
Portugal et 4 heures en Finlande par
exemple mais en dehors de l'Union
Européenne et c'est pas gagné le Chili
par exemple change d'heure une semaine
plutôt que Paraguay sauf que ces deux
pays sont vraiment très très proches en
résumé le changement d'heure c'est le
bordel pour la France j'ai une astuce
aussi qui vous permettra de savoir quand
est-ce qu'on avance notre montre et
quand est-ce qu'on recule pas besoin
d'être mentaliste pour retenir ça vous
allez voir vers avril on avance et vers
octobre pour eux on recule et quand on
avance notre montre on dort moins parce
qu'on se lève plutôt pour le retenir tu
peux te dire bah si je suis en avance
c'est que je me lève plutôt que
d'habitude
[Musique]
alors hormis le fait qu'on puisse louper
son train ou arriver en retard à un
rendez-vous c'est quoi les répercussions
du changement d'heure sur notre santé
tic tac c'est aussi le bruit de notre
pendule biologique et il lui suffit
d'une heure de décalage pour que notre
rythme de vie en soit perturbé un
changement horaire qui avait à l'origine
pour but de faire faire des économies
d'énergie mais voilà 18 ans que des
associations contrôleur d'été les
éleveurs et les médecins pédiatres
tentent de prouver que cette mesure
outre qu'elle n'a qu'à effet relatif sur
l'économie serait plutôt néfaste à la
santé ce changement horaire fragilise
les enfants et perturbe leur métabolisme
hormonaux il leur faut plusieurs
semaines pour se régler sur leur nouveau
rythme en les immunisant d'autant moins
contre les maladies l'horloge biologique
c'est le métronome de notre corps il est
situé dans la zone du cerveau qu'on
appelle l'hypothalamus elle se
synchronise sur une journée de 24 heures
définie par l'alternance du jour et de
la nuit c'est ce qui nous permet de nous
régler d'avoir des repères temporels
pour se lever le matin pour ressentir la
fin pour ressentir la fatigue le
changement d'heure c'est un vrai
problème qui peut engendrer des troubles
de l'endormissement par exemple et de la
tension la mélatonine c'est l'hormone du
sommeil elle régule le rythme du sommeil
et de l'éveil en faisant de deux heures
de lumière basse atteignée pour
déclencher l'endormissement donc quand
il commence à faire nuit à 21h30 ou à
22h l'été ça décale l'heure de
l'endormissement et en plus on dort une
heure de moins mais ça s'arrête pas là
ça crée des troubles de l'appétit des
troubles de l'humeur ou encore une
capacité de travail moins efficace vous
voyez que même si changer d'une heure ça
semble anecdotique certains
scientifiques soutiennent que changer
d'une heure et plus néfaste qu'un gros
gros décalage horaire genre quand tu vas
en vacances selon l'Institut national du
sommeil et de la vigilance le nombre
d'accidents sur la route et de blessures
au travail serait plus élevé au cours
des jours qui suivent en fait le
changement d'heure les jours
d'ajustements qui suivent le passage à
l'heure d'été par exemple mais quand
même pas rien il faut donc accepter que
notre corps a une réadaptation à faire
et peut-être même si préparer un petit
peu plus par exemple en s'exposant à la
lumière naturelle le matin pour mieux se
réveiller la vitamine D c'est une très
banalier ou en faisant des siestes qui
en a la possibilité dans la journée et
surtout en éteignant les écrans une
heure avant de se coucher mais ça ça
vaut pour tout le temps si vous
souhaitez avoir mon sommeil c'est
vraiment le genre de conseil que tout le
monde connaît et que personne n'applique
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on fait vraiment des économies
d'énergie avec ça oui est-ce que c'est
suffisamment impactant pas tellement
d'après l'Agence de l'environnement et
de la maîtrise de l'énergie il y a en
effet une baisse de consommation
d'électricité de
0,07% en moyenne en 2019 plus de 4
millions d'Européens souhaité mettre fin
à ce changement d'heure et le Parlement
européen avait approuvé la suppression
du dispositif pour 2021 donc chaque pays
aurait donc dû choisir l'heure qui
voulait garder celle d'été ou celle
d'hiver bon avec le covid ils ont eu
d'autres petites priorités à gérer et ça
a pas bougé depuis nous en France on
était pour garder celle d'été là encore
certains disent que celle-ci elle sert
pas à grand chose étant donné que le
jour se lève plus tard et donc on
utilise plus d'électricité artificielle
le matin en gros personne n'est d'accord
sur l'heure qu'il faudrait adopter là
encore un ça divise vous vous aimeriez
quoi d'ailleurs vous préférez vivre à
l'heure d'été à leur divers ou vraiment
vous en fichez royalement comme moi
dites-moi dans les commentaires mais oui
moi pour être honnête je vivrai à leur
compte donnera en fait je me poserai pas
tellement la question le seul truc que
ça changerait pas c'est que mes
spectacles commenceraient toujours à
l'heure voilà parce que je suis très
psychorigide là-dessus mon spectacle de
mentalisme du mot et de science est
toujours en tournée vous avez les dates
qui s'affichent n'hésitez pas à venir le
voir on se rencontre d'ailleurs à la fin
c'est le nouveau spectacle avec une
grande exceptionnelle le 22 novembre
2023 la salle Pleyel il va y avoir des
grosses nouveautés si vous avez déjà vu
le spectacle vous allez pas le
reconnaître les liens sont dans la
description à très bientôt Ciao